was this like you know
recklessness
in character for you like when you
started doing this stuff for a big
brother and like if a friend who you
grew up with saw that would they be like
there he goes again or would they be
like whoa knoxville's like a great
question well i i you know honestly i
was a little rambunctious but i wasn't
the most
wild or rambunctious guy at the school
you weren't like let's jump off the roof
and let's [ __ ] do this no not really
yeah
but i mean the people who knew you when
you were in high school in grade school
and they saw you on jackass where
they're like wave where'd this go no no
it wasn't it's not a shock to them
because i was a loudmouth and you know
was always in some some kind of trouble
but uh
it wasn't that big of a shock but i
wasn't the wildest or
by far
the toughest but i mean that's the thing
about jackass none of us are that tough
right so it's like i think that's what
people can connect with this we're not
some mancho guys out there trying to uh
you know uh
there is
uh
an every man
well i mean we are every man
yeah dude